the second of germany's three parties to
lead the next government has just
approved a deal to take power
at a special party convention more than
92 percent of the delegates of the
liberal free democrats or fdp said yes
to the three-way coalition agreement the
social democrats who will lead the
government approved it yesterday the
greens will release the results of their
member vote tomorrow
once all three parties give their
go-ahead the german parliament can vote
in the new government next week
here's what fdp leader christian linda
said earlier today in voicing his
support for the agreement
i'm convinced that this country will
profit from this coalition
a new
and that's why dear party friends i'm
asking you here today to approve this
coalition agreement
let's get started germany is waiting for
this new departure
and with me now in the studio is dw
correspondent benjamin alvarez gruber a
benjamin you were there all day you know
when they were preparing to vote tell us
what does the fdp bring to the policy
mix of the new government
it's a very interesting mix and for the
business ftp party what's really
important is digital infrastructure when
it comes to schools when it comes to
helping make germany fit for the digital
age that's something they've been
pursuing during their election campaign
and that's also where they really really
have a lot of young voters when it comes
to first-time voters the ftp and the
greens
so both of the king makers of this
year's election they had a very good
result there so they want on one side
that when it comes to digital
infrastructure but also when it comes to
finances and that's very important
because the fdp the leader that we just
heard christian lindner will be
germany's new finance minister and
therefore also in charge of the purse of
germany and that has an effect not only
on the government and on germany but
also in europe they're in charge of the
purse of the government their anti-tax
and spend the greens who are voting
tomorrow are kind of more spend spent
spent let's say the environment that's a
big fault line in the new government
isn't it exactly and it will not be easy
also for them to find agreements they
want to change all of these parties said
that they want to change the status quo
after so many years of the conservative
block and the social democrats being in
a government together but now of course
the money is not we need to do something
but where to put this money and where to
spend it as well and of course one of
the top priorities of the government is
the covet 19 pandemic and it's not just
the health ministry but of course the
finance ministry where can we spend the
money how can we help business how can
we increase investment right and
therefore the ftp is also pledging to
not increase taxes yeah it's been a big
test of their ideas um and do you think
like the pandemic will along with the
other policy challenges um force the
fdp's hand or force it to i know they've
been talking about sort of off-budget
purses like will create some kind of
bond scheme to finance infrastructure is
that is that something in the offing
well they have to see how the other
parties will also lead when it comes to
their ministries and what they want to
do of course the situation is difficult
and this new government is facing a new
crisis i mean the incoming government is
also playing an important role when it
comes to administering boosts such as
they created this crisis team with the
three parties so the greens the social
democrats and the fdp also will have a
crisis team that will actually help them
also when it comes to financing but of
course the plans that they had during
this election campaign might also change
due to the current situation where we
have overwhelmed hospitals and of course
the priorities will start there and what
christian lintna said today is that it's
important not to be disappointed when
all the plans and all the ideas that our
party has can be implemented immediately
yeah sounds like he's preparing people
i'm not gonna gaze into the crystal ball
for possible change but uh thanks so
much for that insight uh dw's benjamin
alvarez gruber who was at the fdp
meeting today
you